casi 50% de escépticos frente a las
vacunas contra el cob y 19 en suiza
tanto en la población como en la
comunidad científica predomina la
precaución y en crown oposión la
fusilación hay una gran proporción de la
población que está en completa duda e
incertidumbre por una simple razón que
yo mismo entiendo ya que la comparto
sólo hemos tenido comunicados de prensa
mini kids es para moodysson cij y que no
es mucho para los científicos y los
médicos poder decir al señor y la señora
x oye escuche les recomiendo que se
ponga esta vacuna porque leí en un
comunicado de prensa que la vacuna era
segura y efectiva fresco en reacciones
de cierre eficaz con casi 350 mil casos
y menos de 5.000 muertes suiza se
encuentra entre los países menos
golpeado por la pandemia una situación
lograda sin haber decretado nunca un
confinamiento estricto
en suiza no estamos en la situación
catastrófica de eeuu tenemos el mismo
virus en todas partes pero hemos logrado
limitarlo con medidas realmente fuertes
con medidas que son restrictivas
la vida individual restrictivas para la
economía etcétera etcétera pero no
estamos totalmente abrumados hasta el
punto de otros países en este momento
[Música]
veía acción en el país anuncia que tiene
varios equipos trabajando sobre el tema
y que seguirá analizando los resultados
de las campañas de vacunación semana
tras semana sin prisa suiza no espera
vacunar antes de 2021